Commencement is
just a lot of fun.
To see the students celebrate,
and see the families
and everybody so
excited and so happy,
there's just a ton of energy.
Today we are all
here volunteering
for our 2017
commencement ceremony
that's going to
be happening here
at the University of Arizona.
My job is to help the
students get into the stadium.
And just making sure
that they're excited as
they enter the stadium.
Make sure we get
safety in place,
make sure they're being
safe while they celebrate.
My job today is called SOS.
Which means that our
tiny team of five
responds to really any and
every situation that might
need additional assistance.
This is probably my sixth year.
A lot of my friends volunteered,
and so I said, why not?
That sounds like fun.
It's a way to meet new
people and other people
that I work with.
I spend a lot of time
throughout the year
bringing in brand new Wildcats.
And I've actually
been here long enough
where I've seen the students
that I've recruited when they
were in high school
graduate, which is just
a really special feeling.
It's a celebration of it all.
Really celebrating our students
and their accomplishments
while they've been here.
Graduating from the University
of Arizona is a huge deal.
And it's really important
to us that we send them out
with a bang.
Literally, fireworks.